los embajadores de francia estados
unidos alemania y otros siete países
occidentales no tienen cabida en turquía
esta frase ha sido utilizada hoy mismo
por depresión de turco recep tayip
erdogán en un viaje a áfrica y le ha
pedido al ministro de exteriores turco
que empiece a abrir diligencias contra
estos diez embajadores occidentales por
un comunicado que publicaron hace tan
sólo unos días en el que pedían la
liberación inmediata del activista turco
osman cabal a osman cava la lleva en la
cárcel de 2017 cuatro años en prisión
preventiva esperando hacer a ser juzgado
mientras es acusado de conspirar contra
el gobierno turco y conspirar para
derrocar a recep tayip erdogán sin
embargo este juicio ha sido considero
como un juicio farsa tanto por los
embajadores europeos como por el
tribunal europeo de derechos humanos que
ha pedido inmediatamente a turquía que
libere a la activista osman cábala sino
turquía loas y turquía no lo hace podrá
ser sancionada por este órgano del cual
turquía forma parte los embajadores de
hecho a muchos de los cuales asistieron
al juicio que tuvo lugar hace dos
semanas en estambul pidieron en ese
momento también la liberación de osman
cavaron un momento de las relaciones
entre la unión europea
para sanz uno de sus peores momentos en
muchas décadas